[Music]
instagram
from jacqueline here's a good one riddle
me this how do i make sure that my dad
with severe depression feels loved
even when he treats me badly
purposefully
and purposefully says hurtful things to
me
you got to draw hard boundaries there
peop people
need to feel loved but they don't have
permission to hurt you
in route to that love right and so
you may write him a letter you may hold
firm boundaries but you number one
don't let anybody hurt you with or
without your permission
so you don't solve his depression by
getting abused absolutely not
becoming a punching bag as a matter of
fact that will probably harm his
depression
it will make it worse because he makes
him feel like the schlep that he is so
what somebody like that needs is really
firm boundaries from someone that cares
about them
and they will lean up against those
boundaries and see if they're real and
if they hold and if they're firm
and then if you write them a letter they
can hold something right it's tangible
they can see it then go back to it then
go back to it and as they get well
as he puts in the work that only he can
put in
then he can he can reinterpret that
letter over time but yeah so what's the
letter sound like
dear dad things are dark and i want you
to know that i love you
i have and things have been hard and you
haven't treated me fairly over the years
you haven't treated or maybe not fairly
you've hurt me over the years and i want
you to know i forgive you and i love you
and it's short and it's sweet and it's
direct you may not even have to
to include the abuse part in there but
just let somebody know that they're
loved
that they can circle back to it and
circle back to it okay so that's the
encouragement
correct without the uh physical presence
to allow the abuse absolutely not
okay and so you're standing there later
in the kitchen
because it's christmas and uh
he says something nasty then we will
already have
me and my family already have had that
discussion and we will pack up our
things and we'll walk out the door
and i will not go on a vacation where i
don't have enough money to go to a hotel
if i don't need if i
with an abusive family member that
i can't leave right i won't have already
had that conversation with my wife
right um and it'll be no fanfare will be
no drama
i'm the one that went into that knowing
this could happen we're gonna pack my
things up i'm not gonna hold it too
tightly and then we're gonna go
nobody has permission to hurt me or my
family and that starts with my boundary
so it's up front um you know we don't
we're not gonna we're not gonna do this
correct so if you're gonna do this
that's gonna mean we can't be here
correct so i don't have anybody abusive
in my family but
i've got a whole herd of people coming
to my house
and i sent an email saying here's where
everyone's sleeping arrangements are
going to be here's what they're going to
look like who's going to share a
bathroom and who's not
here's what we will not talk about while
we're here and here's what we are going
to do while we're here which is going to
be low-key and peaceful and chill
and we're going to be respectful we're
going to spend a lot of time outdoors
and i want to give everybody notice up
front you are free to not come and we're
going to love you
and if that's not where you're at this
year great but i don't want people to
come and be surprised and then there'd
be tension i'm just gonna call it
call it what it is before everybody gets
there and that's me trying to be
have boundaries and be mature and know
what i'm getting with my lovely family
who's coming in the number of times
grown kids go back to their old home
and who sleeps where is a problem
there's probably a book in that of
course there is wow
and it's strange too right this is the
dave ramsey show